Okay, so I'm just going to cover, by the way, welcome to the call once again.
If you are brand new to this group and it's your first call, welcome to Digital Landlords
Live, which we're going to be doing every single bloody week.
Yeah, every week, every Tuesday, 7 a.m.
MST.
I understand it's not the most convenient time.
By the way, if you guys can hear me, please let me know.
I have my mic plugged in and sometimes it does a little funny business.
So anyway, if you're brand new to this group, you're going to see me going live every single
week.
I think over the course of almost three years now, there's only been two times that I haven't
been live and I got stuck in the bush.
And I literally was planning on being back at my hotel.
I was in Africa and I just couldn't do it.
Every other situation, it's either me or I've got somebody live.
And I think in those situations, I still put up a replay or gave you guys something.
So make sure to set your calendars every single Tuesday, 7 a.m.
You will see me going live, OK?
Real quick, the only thing that I want to cover is I guess maybe two things.
Number one is if you didn't catch, was it last week or the week before?
Maybe it was a couple of weeks ago.
But if you did not catch the live I did with Ryan Dalton, you guys need to go check that
out.
Find that really quick.
Guys, if you haven't been messing around, playing around with the tool, the rank and
rent engine tool, this thing is making business so much easier than when I was coming up.
Let me go ahead and find that real quick.
I'm going to lose my train of thought.
Where the heck is that live?
I know it's got to be right here at the top.
Let me just scroll just a tiny bit.
Where the heck is it at?
Search it.
Hold on.
Oh, that's weird.
That's weird because that thing got a lot of views.
Hold on.
Give me a sec.
I want to just share this live in the chat.
OK, I'm going to search it.
Hold on.
One sec.
Tool.
OK, there it is.
Hold on.
Got it.
And boom.
OK.
If you guys have not watched this, check this out.
By the way, Stephanie, what's going on?
That's the only other person I saw that looks new from what I was saying before.
OK.
If you guys didn't watch that, I'll try to even pin that.
That is such a good live.
Just real quick in a nutshell, guys, Ryan Dalton has built this very cool tool that
has basically taken everything that you need to build and scale your rank and rent agency.
And he's put it into a tool.
Go to rankandrentengine.com.
If anyone remembers the exact code, I think it's Ignition24.
All caps.
I'm going to type that.
I think that's what it is.
Ignition24, I think.
And what that's going to allow you guys to do.
It's a beta discount.
So we're in the week, basically the beginning of week three of beta for that software.
Now I've been through it.
I spent time almost every day.
Yesterday, I spent about 30, 35 minutes doing more due diligence.
And man, that's not perfect.
We're going to be giving him feedback.
We're going to be making changes, whatever.
The thing that I love about it is with some of these other tools, the SEMrush, the Mangles,
whatever, we don't have control over it because it's just a tool that somebody else owns.
And with this one, like real time, we can give Ryan feedback and say, hey, what about
this feature?
What about this feature?
And it's made for rank and rent.
There's other tools that people use for rank and rent, like high level and lead snap and
stuff like that.
Also, they built it for a wider platform in an effort to attract more people, which is
fine.
However, I think they did it wrong because this was built specifically for rank and rent
and rank and rent only.
And so if you are in rank and rent, it makes total sense.
So anyway, guys, no pressure, but I am telling you, you can, in fact, you know what I should
do really quick?
Is there a way I can show you without giving away my secrets?
Hold on.
Let me see if I open this up, if it's going to just show you my entire freaking whatever.
I don't know if I can do that.
Let's see.
Yeah, I'll just do it anyway.
Let me just do this really quick.
I'm going to show you guys two seconds and we're going to get going on this call.
One second.
Okay.
Ready?
Hopefully you guys can see my screen.
I just want to show you guys really quick.
So go rankandrentengine.com, but it's literally this dope tool.
You've got the task tracker, which is like, guys, I was paying for this software.
Let's see.
What software was I using?
Kind of like this.
This is a software we were using kind of like, what's that?
I can't even remember what it's called.
It's the one where you just move stuff around, not air table, something else.
Anyway, I was paid for a software that basically did this.
You could just drag your tasks like this.
I think it might've been Pipe Drive, but Francesca's put all these in and yeah, you could just
track all your tasks you need to do inside your agency.
So we've been messing around with that a bit.
You've got your due diligence, which is dope.
You can really crank out due diligence.
I used to spend an hour per due diligence to really look at a city and now I can pipe
everything in and I'm able to knock out a due diligence in like less than 12 minutes.
And I think I can get that down to about seven minutes once I really get the hang of this,
which is incredible.
It literally computes the data like that.
Then you have your site portfolio.
You can keep track of all your sites.
You got your prospecting pipeline and there's literally a software called Pipe Drive that
this does the same thing as you've got your client list, all your leads, all your calls.
You can buy your tracking numbers.
You can analyze a site, which is the same thing that SEMrush does.
You get your keyword planner and this is version one.
So I'm getting pretty pumped about this.
Our goal as an agency, and I don't know if you guys saw this post by Francesca.
We did an estimate on Thursday of last week and I say Francesca did it.
We gave them an option of $7,500 or $10,000 per month.
That was their two options.
Now we may not even get the deal at all, but those are the type of deals that get me juiced
up, get me excited.
Those are the ones I'll get involved in.
If it's 10 grand a month, I'll show up to a call, but I'm not even including that.
Our goal is to add, by December 1st, to add an extra $10,000 per month to our agency.
Not to my digital landlords program, whatever.
We're going to keep growing this.
I'm going to keep focusing on this.
We've got a ton of stuff.
We're working on version 3.0.
We're working on new ad stuff, a bunch of stuff.
But just the agency alone, we're going to add an extra $10,000 in the next 45 days.
Mark my words.
And this tool is making it very, very easy.
So anyway, guys, I'm stoked about this.
I've been playing around a lot with this.
And this has taken the Google Sheet, the Airtable, the Pipe Drive, the Google Doc,
the SEMrush, the Mangools, the keyword planner, and you've got one tool that's
focused on rank and rent.
So if you guys haven't already, go play around with this thing.
There's a free version.
But if you use that Ignition 24, then it's 20% off for the first couple of months.
And that's part of the beta.
And we want the feedback and everything else so we can make this as good as possible.
But shout out to Ryan Dalton.
Great job, my friend.
Okay.
That said, guys, let me give a little preface to this call and let's do it.
Let me just get back to my screen.
I lost it.
Hold on.
There it is.
Okay.
Beautiful.
Everyone can still hear me.
What else we got here?
We've got Matt Torres.
What's up?
And Mr.
Kurt Dahlstrom.
Guys, it's crazy to me.
I love this, by the way.
We've got people from all over the world in this call right now.
Like I just saw Corey and Nick.
Corey and Nicholas are like five minutes from me or 10 minutes from me, which is
awesome.
And then we've got on the other extreme, we've got Kurt, who's in China.
He's a resident of China right now.
I think that's what you'd say.
Trying to see if I can recognize anyone else that's in a far flung place.
Some of these people are, some of you guys are in different parts of the states,
but we're all here doing the same thing.
This is the community.
Make sure you guys are in this community every single day.
Make connections.
If you haven't already done your intro post, do it and go find some people that
are in your situation.
You guys can connect.
And like I was saying, Corey and Nicholas, you guys should definitely connect up.
Jahill says, quick question.
What would you say the baseline search volume would?
Okay.
That's the question, right?
So Jahill, I think I know what it is because I've been playing around a lot
with this tool.
That's going to be our topic for our live in the next week or two.
I know I've been saying that for a while, but I really want to make dang sure
that when I say, Hey, it's 50, then it's 50.
But that is one of the beautiful things about having a tool that we can control.
As I can confidently say, when the tool says this, you can be 95% sure there's
going to be enough volume.
And I was talking to Corey Gilbert about this yesterday real quick, and then
we'll get into this call.
And he was asking me about population and I was telling him, Hey, population
does not matter, which is the truth.
It comes down to search volume.
But generally speaking, the bigger the population, the more search volume
there's going to be generally speaking, right?
Not in every case, but in most cases.
Um, but what I would definitely say guys is on your first project, your first five
projects, make sure you're not risking, you know, you want to get into usually a
smaller city, a smaller population means less competition, but not always.
Okay.
So you always want to have like the lowest competition, the lowest population
technically, because that means the lower competition, but you've got to make
sure that you're, you're getting enough search volume.
You don't want to go into a city, um, where, you know, you're running ads,
you're, you're, you're ranking on Google and there's just not enough leads.
Okay.
That's the worst.
And I've done that before and I've done this in too small of cities.
Um, the search volume has been too low, et cetera.
So I would just recommend on your first couple of projects, make sure you guys
are being safe about going into a city that has enough search volume and you're
not even worried that you're going to not have enough.
Okay.
So I know for example, we're running a deal right now where we have a one pager
in a city in, I think Virginia, and we're having a problem getting leads.
I didn't pick the city, Francesca.
Gosh, dang it.
Francesca picked the city.
It was one of those that looked like low hanging fruit, but it was on the
bordering edge of is there going to be enough volume?
And it's looking like there's not.
And so I don't want you guys to make that mistake.
So make sure there's enough volume, uh, on these first deals.
Don't, don't even risk it.
Make sure you're going to have enough search volume.
Okay.
That said, and Jahill, I promise you that's not going to be a question that's avoided.
I'm that's why I'm in the tool so much.
Part of the reason I'm checking out the due diligence, I want to know this
thing inside and out backwards and forward.
So if I'm going to endorse something, then I need to know it every part of it.
And I do know that there's a few little holes and tweaks we need to make,
but we want to hear your feedback as well.
So, um, Lynel says, how long do you run ads before it's a volume issue?
I know if like, I I'll know it's a volume issue within the first couple of weeks.
Okay.
And, but you have to keep in mind, you have to think about the time of year.
You have to think about, you know, other circumstances.
We've got the election coming up.
We got fricking, we're in the middle of a recession.
People are uncertain.
I've got my business owner right now.
Um, just so you guys know, I have problems too.
I have a business owner that's been with me a long time threatening, not
threatening, but telling me, I don't know, maybe I should just pause till the election.
And we're like, what are you talking about, dude?
What are you freaking talking about?
So there are some weird stuff going on in the world, but we're still pressing for it.
We just made a $10,000 a month offer, right?
So we're still, the companies that are hungry are hungry.
And, uh, that's just the game name of the game.
So hopefully that answers your question.
Um, Daniel Kelly, what does enough volume mean to you?
We're going to cover that.
Um, but for now I would, I don't even want to give you, uh, I would just say,
make sure that your main keyword, if you want to be safe, safe, safe, safe, safe,
make sure your main keyword on, uh, uh, rank and run engine says at least a hundred.
Okay.
That's being very safe.
And I don't think it's going to mean to be near that, but if you want me to do
that without having to go in and check the tool very well, which I'm going to,
if it says a hundred and the CPC is something less than $5 on, you know, two,
three, four of the main keywords, then you probably going to be safe.
Okay.
And if you're looking at population, I know population doesn't matter, but it
can be indicative of how competitive it is.
Um, you know, a hundred thousand plus to be very safe is going to be work.
Now I've gotten deals in cities with 30,000.
Um, so I'm going to try to give you guys the bare minimum search volume.
And then you guys can know that anything above that should work, but for, to be
safe for a quick answer, that's what I would say real quick.
Adair says people are still spending money though.
I just talked to, I just talked to a concrete guy and said they want, they
start three to five pools a week.
People are still spending money in the, in the right parts of the country, the
right mindsets, like people are still spending money, dude.
That's the, that's a great point.
I dare.
Um, okay, guys, let's get in the call.
Uh, today I got a treat for you guys.
I'm going to be bringing on Mr.
Zach Powell.
Um, now I want to just preface this and let you guys know that this call, um,
we're going to take an interesting angle with this call.
For those of you that just got in this program, I don't want you to be confused.
I don't want you to be scatterbrained, whatever.
Zach Powell is crushing it.
Okay.
Now Zach Powell came into this program, I think it was two and a half years ago
and he was in a situation where he was in a job making, and he'll confirm this
thing was like five, six grand a month and he needed to get out of the job as
soon as possible so he could focus on, you know, his business and so he was
sitting there looking like, what's the quickest way I can get out of my job?
And he decided to take this skillset and take it a little bit different angle.
So he's still doing the same thing, but instead of selling the leads, he's
actually just selling the service SEO as a service.
Now you guys might've heard me talk at length about how I don't like to do this.
And that is the truth.
I do not at the time of, of talking at this very moment, think we have an SEO
client, if we do, it's like a, it's like a $500 a month client because
Francesca signed it.
I, I had a bad experience, um, in the long run with SEO because I did it wrong.
Okay.
So I'm going to bring on Zach today.
Zach has been able to figure out how to literally build a business brick by brick.
And I mean that because he's figured out a way to go and get deals where most
people wouldn't even, you know, consider getting deals with these SEO clients.
And he's literally built a business brick by brick and he has built it up to
56,000 or $57,000 per month.
Um, there is a correct way to do this.
And the reason for those of you, like, I want to stand by my, like my belief is
that the true way to scale this thing, the true way to have a business that's
passive that you can build today, get it ranked and not have to spend a ton of
time on it and go and live your life, travel to Dubai, you know, travel to
Africa, coach your kids' soccer team, go be a service missionary, do this, do
that, coach high school football.
That's through Legion.
However, I do understand that if you're in a situation where you're stuck in a
job and you want it, you need to get out of that job so you can focus on this.
Then in, in certain situations, you know, getting a few SEO deals to get those
bills paid is not a bad option, but there's a correct way to do it.
And there's a wrong way to do it.
So I'm going to have Zach come on today.
We're going to be talking about mindset.
We're going to be talking about his strategy.
We're going to be talking about a ton of different stuff, um, that Zach does, but
I just want to say that, so I don't want anyone to get super in the weeds,
confused, whatever.
Guys, SEO is part of lead generation.
We do SEO to get our leads in the long run.
We do the ads, we get the deal.
Then we do the SEO to sustain the deal to then be able to turn off ads.
These go hand in hand, right?
Um, so I just want you guys, again, I don't want to confuse anyone, but Zach has
been doing this in a strategic way.
And you can go, if you do this in a way where you go after people that are
potential lead generation clients, you can get them on an SEO deal and you can
turn around and sell them lead generation.
And the lead generation is going to be the thing that sticks.
And the SEO might be the thing that falls off, but Zach has figured
out some very cool strategies.
He scaled this thing up to $57,000 per month.
Two and a half years ago was making five to seven grand per month.
And I'm going to be bringing him on right now.
So let's welcome Mr.
Zach Powell.
Here he comes.
Look at this handsome devil.
He's joining right now.
Zach Powell.
What's up, bro?
What's up, Nick?
How's it going, man?
Dude, it's going great.
How are you doing?
Doing good.
Thanks for having me on, man.
Yeah, you're welcome, bro.
So you're in, um, you're not at your office office.
Looks like you're at your home office.
Cause we did this call so early.
Right?
Oh, this is the new office is actually a house.
So we bought like an acre, put a sweet house on it.
And this is the new office, man.
It's like, yeah, a house on some land.
Hold on.
So when you say we, was that you and your wife, you and a partner?
Oh yeah.
Sorry.
Me and my wife, we just wanted some land.
So we bought some land and built basically like a new office on the, on the place.
Dude, I love, I love the humility, bro.
So you bought an, you, you built a new house using money that you made
from freaking slinging deals.
Yeah, basically.
That's sick, dude.
When did you guys move?
It was like a month ago.
That's great.
Well, congrats, man.
Is that the, your, your first, like official house house, or have you guys,
is this like second?
Uh, number four.
Oh, you guys are movers.
You guys are, you guys move around.
Okay.
Dope.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's been good.
That's cool, man.
Well, anyway, the reason I said that guys is Zach's usually in his office.
Um, but nothing like a home office, dude, wake up, you know, get the shower
really quick and you're at work in five minutes.
So anyway, congrats on that dude.
And I was just given a little intro.
I don't know if you were listening live, but I was just telling everyone,
you know, for those that are new, um, well, first of all, you,
you're still in Phoenix, right?
Yep.
Yeah.
Queen Creek, just outside Phoenix, bro.
That's a, that's a, that's a, you know, that's the city that we cover in
the training, right?
Oh, that's it.
Yeah.
It's a great city.
Tons of people, tons of business owners.
Yeah.
So Zach, Zach was, Zach started in here when we did version one.
So version 2.0, bro, it's Queen Creek.
So, um, we'll make sure to go ahead and saturate Queen Creek for you.
I'm just kidding, bro.
So let's talk about your story.
I know you've shared it before, but just kind of give everyone the, the two
minute version of how we got here to $57,000 per month, where you were at.
And then, um, yeah, like how you, where you were at, how you got into digital.
And then, um, maybe the short version of how you got to $57,000 per month
through simple SEO deals, dude.
Yeah.
Good question.
So brief overview is my dad actually owns a carpet cleaning company.
Um, and he was just overpaying for all this digital marketing stuff for years.
So I started helping him kind of on the side of my job, like three and a half
years ago, and then, you know, helping him get reviews, do a better side,
just kind of helping him.
But then, um, yeah, I bought into your course and realized like, Whoa, this
can go much bigger than just helping my dad.
Um, and so then I started going hard and started building Legion sites, doing
SEO deals, just like anything I can get my hands on.
And then I saw a path to quit my job.
And when I saw that path, I was like, Oh shoot, I'm going to do that.
Um, and I actually got laid off with a bunch of people cause it's like public
company I worked for downsized and I had four months of severance and I was like,
this is my four months to just grind and make as much, get as much monthly
recurring revenue as possible, as quickly as possible to quit my job.
Um, so I was just talking to anybody and any deal I could get, I was, I was
getting my dad's friends and then I'm cold calling and it started just being
where like all these SEO deals were just falling in my lap.
And I was like, I have to do this.
I have to stack these $500 a month deals, $300 or whatever that person wants and
just quickly build their site.
Obviously someone in the Philippines built their site and I'm stacking it up.
So that's what I did.
Um, got to like 6,500 monthly recurring revenue and quit my job or I guess got
laid off, got another job, but quit that within a couple of weeks and just started
going, um, and it's just kind of from there, been explosive.
Like once I hired someone in the Philippines to call businesses for me every
day, now I just talk with business owners all the time and bring them over, bring
them over to me because they're unhappy with their situation.
Now I actually got a year ago, I brought on the sales guy, so I don't do the
sales anymore, but we're growing.
We're at like, yeah, 57,000 monthly recurring revenue, just stacking those
easy wins where it's hilarious.
Like sometimes we do live transfers now.
So like the person in the Philippines will call a business owner and then if
they're like unhappy with their website, they'll just live transfer to my sales
guy and sometimes like within 45 minutes, it goes from cold call deal closed.
Now we have a new client because all the work is after they pay, which that's
kind of fun, but yeah, it's just, it's just stacking.
And now, um, systems are built pretty well and it just keeps growing.
So that's exciting.
That's kind of the story in a nutshell.
Yeah, it's been, it's been a ride.
That's been fun.
Yeah.
And obviously there's so many details that you weren't able to cover there,
but that's in a nutshell.
And that's why I called this live like brick by brick, because, you know, I
think sometimes we see people, they grow really rapidly and sometimes they
land a monster client and it completely, like I've heard of people getting
like these franchise deals and then they add like 20, 30,000 revenue, right?
Um, which is great, but the way that Zach's built his business is literally
brick by brick, $500 a month, $700 a month, $300 a month.
So if tomorrow Zach had five people call him and cancel, that's not really
going to do that much to his business.
He's still going to be at the same spot and that's a really comfortable place to
be. It's a really free, mentally free place to be.
So, um, for those that have never heard you before, I want you to kind of just
give an outline of like your process, what you guys are doing.
You don't need to give too many details.
Um, but just like how you guys are getting these deals, because right now
you're, you're removed from the equation, which is you've done it really well.
And so now you have this team, you have this system where, and I'm not going to
like, I'm going to let you talk about it, but you guys are, are finding certain
people, you're, you're cold calling using a certain, uh, type of person.
And then you have a, like, just kind of explain how you're going about getting
deals from like a high level overview.
Totally.
So it's actually crazy how many companies are unhappy with just their website and
their, their online presence, their SEO.
And so we just target those people.
Like, we'll just get a big list of like electricians or a big list of
plumbers or a big list of everybody who uses a certain marketing company
that we know sucks.
We go to their website and see, Oh, their pricing is $800 a month and they're
terrible and they have 5,000 clients.
We'll grab their client list, call all those guys and just bring them over,
bring them over, bring them over.
Um, so essentially the whole concept or a big piece of the concept is like
having offshore talent that speak perfect English, calling business owners,
finding people who are unhappy.
It's a super short script that we have, but like, they just find the unhappy
clients, unhappy business owners.
They talk with our sales guys and we bring them over.
Um, and it's, it's an easy pitch because they've already been thinking
about switching, like they don't like who they have, like there's so many
pain points and we just find one pain point and then, you know, we just
transfer them over to us.
So when I was in college, like I sold direct TV door to door.
And when I sold direct TV, all my sales were people who had dish network or
AT&T U-verse and switched them to direct TV to save them money and give them
like more channels.
And so that clicked with me in digital marketing.
And I was like, because the issue for almost everybody, like I guess in the
chat, like guys in the chat, just write down like, what is the hardest part
of growth for you?
I'm like curious, like what people struggle with when it comes to growth,
like in the chat, light it up if you want and I'll read, I have it up right
here, but generally it's in a couple buckets for most people.
But yeah, just throw in the chat what, why you struggle with growth.
For me, it was sales.
And I was like, I'm having trouble like actually collecting money.
And that made me really mad because I was just like grinding, grinding,
grinding, but I wasn't collecting money.
And I was like, this freaking sucks.
I don't want to work for nothing.
And so I was like, what is the easiest deal possible?
And I thought back to my direct TV days and I was like, the easiest sale for
me to quit my job and start getting a little bit of money coming in as I'm
starting out was just a transfer.
If I can save someone money and give them a better product, that's
just like an easy switch.
They're already paying 500 bucks a month, 800 bucks a month, 400 bucks a month.
If I can just switch that to me, but give them better service, it's an easy switch.
And so I realized that there's actually thousands of business owners in the
U S paying big marketing companies and those marketing companies are doing a
terrible job and why don't I just like steal a little bit of their thousands
and thousands of clients, why don't I just take a little piece and just keep
doing that until I quit my job.
So that's what I did.
Um, Spencer saying sales for sure.
I mean, I think most people think that like the hardest part of growth is sales.
So thinking of direct TV, I was like, if I can make easy switches, that's so easy.
Um, and so that's how we set everything up, calling business owners, finding
unhappy ones, and then our pitch is essentially doing them our research.
Like everyone's doing due diligence, you know, that skill set you guys already
have, it's essentially just doing due diligence for that company and their
business and explaining, oh yeah, your website, your online presence isn't
good because of these things.
Um, we can do a much better job than whoever you have now that doesn't care.
Now they have a small business, this, you care about them and they just switch to
you and you're just stacking that monthly current revenue.
So that's what it's been like for me.
And, uh, go tying that into the training.
It's funny.
So, cause some of you guys may know I had a background in door to door
sales as well, and we, we, we learned the same thing, uh, Zach sold TV.
I sold alarm systems, but, uh, it didn't take long before you realized, Hey, if I
knock on a door that doesn't have an alarm system, I have to sell them on the
idea of having home security, adding a bill.
And on top of that, I have to convince them they should use my company.
And then you knock on that door that already has another company, ADT, and all
you have to do is convince them to pay their money to you instead of the other
company.
And instead of having an hour and 15 minute sale, it was like a 20 minute
sale, not emotional, logical.
Oh, that makes sense.
Same price or less.
And I get all this extra stuff, better service.
Yeah, that's, that's a no brainer.
So that's why, when we talk about building the list, we go after people who
are already paying for these services in a similar way.
Zach's doing that exact same thing.
Those are the people that he's targeting.
So here's the misconception that I always had about SEO is I did it and I
did it incorrectly because when I did SEO, I was such, it was such a desperate
spot.
I didn't have severance pay.
I just like, I was on the tail end of a failed business, right?
So you were a little bit smarter.
You had like a little bit of a runway and you were smart about it.
And me, I just like failed the business.
And I was like, I need money today.
So any money I was taking, I had a restaurant client.
I had a, like a band, like a wedding band that played like music at weddings, dude.
I had all kinds of weird clients and I could never sell them Legion A, B, I
didn't, none of them had commonalities.
There was all these just like unknowns.
They were all over the country.
I had just a bunch of weird stuff.
I was trying to get the biggest deals possible.
I was convincing people who weren't doing SEO to do SEO.
And I just had this weird smorgasbord of, of a portfolio of SEO.
And I also had big, like I had this client that was, this is when I decided SEO is
not my game, which I've changed my mind on it for sure.
Otherwise I wouldn't have brought Zach on here, but I was in, I was in a SeaWorld.
Zach, you've been to SeaWorld with the kids yet, bro?
San Diego?
Yeah.
I haven't been there, but driven past it to the beach.
Yeah, dude.
It's a scam, bro.
It's a, especially if you've been to Disneyland, you go to SeaWorld and you're
like, bro, this is like the, the wish.com version of Disneyland.
Um, it was cool when I was a kid.
It's not anymore.
No.
Uh, anyway, I'm at SeaWorld with the kids and I get this call from my
client and keep in mind, I only got like six, seven clients at the time.
And this client was paying me $4,000 a month.
Okay.
Also, I was going into really hard niches.
I was, it was a foundation repair client.
And dude, I just knew when I saw the call, I'm like, this guy's going to cancel.
And that's going to be literally at the time that was almost half of my revenue.
It was half of my revenue.
Took the call, dude, missed the whale show, go out over and he's
like, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm done, dude.
It just ruined my vacation.
Right.
I'm like, you know, you're like sitting there cringing when you're
getting the churros now, cause the $5 churros, like it feels a lot more
expensive than it did.
And I was just like, dude, this isn't going to work for me.
But the mistake that I made is I didn't have a criteria.
Similarly to you guys have heard my story.
I tell you guys when you're doing lead generation, go into the boring
niches, go into these niches that are tried and true.
Zach's does, he has a very strict criteria for who he works with.
He's he, he, he, he's got all these different like boxes that have to be
checked and if they're checked, that's his person he's going to go in.
He's going to get the deal.
He already knows everything about who they're working with, where
the pain points are.
And on top of that, he set up a system where he doesn't even have to do it.
So what I want you guys to understand is if you are going to do SEO, there's
a strategic way to do it and I want you guys to remember people that need
SEO only want SEO because they want, generally speaking, want phone calls.
So if you can get somebody on an SEO deal, you could turn around and you
could sell them lead generation if they're the right client.
Now, if you go get a restaurant deal, it's going to be difficult to sell
them lead generation, if not impossible.
If you go get an e-comm company that you're ranking their website for
this specific product, first of all, that's going to be tough, but it's
going to be tough to sell leads.
But if you do what Zach does, he targets home service businesses in certain
niches that are unhappy at a certain price point, dude, he's just like, it's
like a shooting fish in a barrel.
You know what I mean?
Um, and so anyway, I want you guys to understand that.
Now, Zach, I know I'm going to forget about this, but Zach, he's he grab your
link because I know you did like a webinar like a year ago or maybe like
six, seven months ago, so Zach started doing this and he had a couple of
buddies, just like I did, they were like, dude, what, like, I'm sure they
were looking at you like, whoa, dude, like how's your, your situation change.
And I know you're not a flashy person.
So they, they probably took a while for them to catch on, but, uh, they were
like, what are you doing?
And Zach started helping.
I think it was like his brother-in-law and his buddy, and then they
started having success.
And so he ended up starting and he put together a training where he
actually has his own thing.
He teaches people how to do this.
So, um, Zach, I do want you to drop that webinar if you would in the chat.
And then I'll pin that.
So for those of you guys that are like, Hey, you want to learn more and, and
see what Zach's up to click on that, watch the webinar.
It's very cut and dry to the point.
Um, I'm actually, uh, I'm actually in that it's I've been through it.
It's really, really solid.
And there's a lot of stuff that you can also use for lead generation, just the
concepts and the systems and everything.
Um, but, uh, so yeah, drop that.
And then we're going to get into Q and a here in a second, but, um, tell everyone
like what your team looks like.
This is what's, I think so impressive dude is like two questions that we're
going to get into Q and a, what does your team look like?
And then what is your day to day look like right now at $57,000 per month?
Awesome question.
So yeah, first I just put the link.
It's actually just Zach Powell.co.
Um, it's just like a, I built in like five minutes.
It looks retarded, but it has two videos.
So the first one just shows like my strike page.
So like, you guys actually know I'm not just like some fake dude.
It shows my strike page.
And I talk about like each of the steps and kind of what I learned.
Um, and then the next one, um, I explained more about like what I teach
and the success of people, like the first beginning students, whatever.
Um, but yeah, check out that link if you want.
Uh, but yeah, so first my team, um, and I'll kind of answer this in phases.
So when I started out, it was just me obviously doing everything.
And then I hired, um, an appointment center or an SDR in the Philippines.
And he just started calling people every day.
And that's what just really got us going because now I could talk
to way more business owners and therefore close way more deals.
So from there, hired a couple more appointment setters, hired, um,
website builders first, just hourly.
Cause it was super cheap, like four or $5 an hour.
And now these people would build my websites in like eight to 10 hours,
brand new website.
And I paid like 40 bucks for it.
It's crazy.
So I added website builders, then added like citation builders,
um, added, um, SEO specialists.
So now the team, we have, uh, 23 people.
There's like, uh, you know, six SDRs calling business owners.
There's, um, about six SEO specialists, four website builders,
like a support email support.
Um, and yeah, so that's, that's basically the team.
About 23 of us for all of that.
Is that all out overseas?
It's all overseas except the sales guy, um, is here in the office with me in
Arizona, and then, um, I actually have like, uh, like general manager basically
in the U S as well, that kind of like manages the whole team.
So my day to day, um, I mean, it's kind of lie, dude.
Cause like we were going to do this call last week.
He's like, I'm out for the week.
And I didn't even ask, but I bet I guarantee you were doing something
adventurous like that, right?
Yeah.
I just went on like a surf trip to Nicaragua for a week, which was insane.
Um, I love not biking, but essentially, um,
like all of these systems are now built where I'm not doing any of
like the day to day stuff that's all covered.
My mind is purely focused on like new strategies and growth and like, um,
and helping my team Excel.
So like, I love training my team because these are people that
are making $500 a month, but now they can have like the best training in the world.
You know, I'm, I pay for other mentors, big money to like learn
the best of the best.
And then I bring that to like my group and my employees.
And so that's what I love doing now is like helping individual cause
they're like, if your employees grow as people, they're going
to help your business more.
So I'm training my employees.
I'm training my group, my connections.
Like I'm just helping everyone elevate and distributing that knowledge.
I love doing that.
And then I love like analyzing businesses or like aspects of the
business and improving those things.
So like now we have a head of digital marketing, like a head of our SEO team,
who's like way smarter than me when it comes to SEO.
And, you know, I talk with him once a week and we just like bounce ideas off
each other and then he goes and implements these new strategies to serve
our clients even better on the sales side.
I love thinking about sales.
I'm like, how can we be more effective?
So we used to, our SDRs used to set appointments for our closer, but
now it's just a live transfer.
They have them on the phone and boom, live transfer and the account
executive takes over and it helps our conversion rates.
So just looking at stuff like that and continually improving the business.
It's how I spend my, my day to day.
And it's pretty dang fun.
Like it's fun in the beginning cause it's like life or death and you
just got to keep adding those deals.
And now this day is more like, um, I got to look inward and become a better
leader because that's what I'm doing.
So I'm really focused on like personal growth, helping my team grow training
and implementing new processes.
And the more I can learn, the more I can implement in my company, which
is a pretty fun spot to be.
So, yeah, so you went from like day to day in the business and now you've
been able to extract yourself and most of your time's on the business, right?
Kind of strategic decisions and, you know, visionary, where's the company
going, all that kind of stuff.
And that, that to me is the fun stuff.
I do actually believe it or not.
When I do get in the weeds, I have fun because it's exciting.
I kind of like makes you, you know, like when you were doing door to door sales
and then you were like a trainer, whatever.
And then it's like, it's so fun to get back in with the reps and
like, go close the deal.
Right.
And I still, dude, I still like to do that to this day.
Francesca closes most of our deals, um, you know, on the agency side.
And then for the program side is Kyle, but I'll jump on, I was on the
phone with Kyle yesterday and I just love to hear people's stories and
like, like that excitement and that also that like people are taking
that step into the unknown.
So, um, but that's a really cool spot that you're in, dude.
Um, real quick, your entire team, apart from your U S based people, how much
are you, basically you have about 20 people that are overseas, roughly.
What's your monthly nut on the 20 people rough, like just guess.
It's like, um, nine or 10,000 a month for like bananas, bro.
That's literally the sound they're living.
Great.
Like they're, they're crushing it.
They're, they're making double, triple one.
Quadruple, like a normal person in the Philippines.
Cause she's so good.
And she's no one else in her family works.
She provides for her parents, her siblings, like everyone around another
guy provides for like his parents, his family, his sister, like they make so
much money that they're able to provide for all these people cause they generally
live in the same house and they're like the breadwinner for like three
generations, their kids, them, and their siblings and their parents.
It's, it's pretty nuts.
So that's awesome.
So I would guess based on what you're telling me out of this 57 grant, what
would you say your profit margin?
Cause that's so guys that there's upsides and downsides to different,
like, uh, this is a, this is the same business.
It's just a different deliverable, right?
Instead of selling the leads, you're selling the service of getting the website
ranked same, same thing you're doing SEO.
Um, but the, the, the downside to SEO is you don't have quite as much control
because you don't own the asset.
However, the upside is you have your profit margins from day one are ridiculous.
Like you're making, like if Zach was doing the work himself, his profit
margins are literally like 99%.
Um, what's your profit?
Would you say on the 57 K it's like, it's gotta be like 80%, right?
75, 80%.
Yeah, it was that for a bit.
I just hired like a bunch of people.
So it was probably like 50% now 40, 40 to 50%, but it's like, I have
two expensive us hires a sales guy, bringing all the sales, a general
manager taking care of everything.
And then after and the team in the Philippines and Pakistan, after that,
it's like, you know, I'm doing what I love.
And I still make that profit, which is pretty cool.
If I, when I was doing the sales, obviously and doing, didn't have the
U S labor, then it was like around 80, 75, 80%.
Now it's about 45%, I'd say.
Yeah.
But, and the thing is though, in order for you to go to a hundred K,
you need those hires.
So you may, it may look like you're taking a step back, but you're just,
you're just basically building that foundation so you can go higher.
Right.
Yeah.
We're in, we're in growth mode now.
Like, um, so yeah, we're going to hit a hundred thousand next year.
So
yeah, I guarantee you.
So, okay.
One last quick question.
I'm going to get into some Q and a, um, the people that you're working with,
what's your top person doing?
Cause I know when we talked like six months ago, one of them was doing
like 15 K or something like that.
Is it like, how many people do you have at 10 K or what's your top person
doing that you're, that you've taught us to.
Oh, like in my course?
Yeah.
Um, actually, actually 54,000.
So that kind of motivated me to get things going.
I'm like, man, people are now going to surpass me.
Which one of them?
Um, that's James.
Okay.
I got James Lincoln.
Yeah.
That's dope, dude.
Um, Mitch Mitch is like over 20 or 30,000 Vinny's over 20 and he's over 20.
Like there's a lot of guys crushing it, but when James started approaching me,
he's like a good friend of mine.
I'm like, dude, I gotta ramp things up and not just like coast.
I love, I love that.
Well, that's a, that's always, he started like a year and a half ago.
Um, and like part-time with his doing his MBA and having a different job at
the same time, but he's crushing it.
Um, I launched the course a year and a half ago.
So if, and the reason I'm asking him this guy's again, this, this is,
if you want to check out his site, I pinned it at the top.
I love Zach's thing.
Cause it's literally like, like he said, it's like a video or two.
And, um, he just talked to him.
He just shows the proof and then he's like, here's my system.
And if you guys want to check it out, here it is.
But, um, I've talked to some of these guys.
I know like what they're up to is I get, it's got my stamp on it.
And so I guess I would say anybody that's in a situation where like
you need to quit your job, um, today, uh, that's something you
should, you should consider looking into.
And it's something you can do in tandem with what we're doing again.
I don't want you to just go picking up random SEO clients, fricking
restaurant this and, um, you know, whatever, try to be strategic.
Like if you're going to get an SEO client and your long-term goal is to do
lead gen, think about, okay, I want to get into these niches.
I want to be in fencing.
I want to be in duck cleaning.
I want to be in tree service, et cetera.
Go get SEO clients in those niches because you can then go and sell
them lead generation on the backend.
And one thing that Zach hasn't even really tapped into in one of these
days, I'm just going to go buy his list is, um, he hasn't even like, to my
knowledge, you haven't really gone and like sold these guys like lead generation.
It's mainly just been the SEO, right?
Mainly the SEO, but it's hilarious how easy it would be.
I just need to set up the systems because people ask me all the time,
like, Hey, uh, yeah, we want to get more leads.
Like, can you help us set up Google ads?
And I'm like, ding, ding, ding.
There's a lead gen client, you know?
Um, but yeah, I just need to implement those, those systems.
We've been working on like a lot of automations and stuff, which is good too.
But yeah, essentially like when you're, if you guys are focusing on.
Like, let's say artificial turf or concrete or bathroom remodels
or whatever your niche is, like.
You can do, this is a, this is a pro tip right here.
There's this thing called outscraper.
Um, and you can, it can pull like thousands of businesses
from Google business profiles.
So use outscraper, grab a list of 5,000, um, concrete companies and have an
SDR call them, and now you're getting a conversation started and you're
building trust with your core market.
And then the easiest way in the door is to just do a better website for them.
They already have a website there to pay for it.
Um, and you can just make it way better.
And now they trust you and now your foot's in the door.
You're already making money from them day one.
Now you can quit your job.
And in your mind, you're like, dude, I already have this connection.
I've already pre-sold it, right?
Like Nick's all about the art of pre-selling.
You basically have a pre-sale because you have this client in your pocket.
They're a concrete company.
They trust you.
They're already paying you.
You know, you have the insights to like how much work they can handle, how
they're growing, like how many jobs they can handle each month.
And you just crush it for them.
And then you're like, Hey, do you want more jobs?
A lot of business owners do Google ads, do whatever.
I actually have leads that are only for you ready to go 10 a month.
And I'll sell them to you for this much.
I'm going to, I was going to sell them to another guy, but I'm glad that
I actually know you because now I can sell them to you.
Do you want them?
You have first right of refusal on these leads.
Of course you're going to take those jobs, right?
It's like the easiest sale up.
So yeah, check out outscraper, check out that system, check out the videos on my,
on my page, I think you guys will get some good thoughts going.
So the other thing, other reason I wanted to have Zach is even if you guys don't
take anything else from this call, because you choose not to, because you
should be taking some nuggets is like, you guys need to realize that there's
like, once you get into a business, cause you guys are in digital landlords.
I've got, I've shown you guys exactly the system that I've used, exactly how I
was able to get to a hundred thousand dollars per month, but as you get going,
you start to see opportunities that you had no idea were there.
So like, I'm pretty sure when Zach started, um, he, you know, got done with
college or whatever, did you graduate college?
You, you got a degree, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
I studied business at BYU.
So yeah, I, I'm guessing you probably didn't imagine yourself like managing
websites for small businesses, like whatever you probably just, it was not
even on your radar, but then you get going, you start doing, and then you
see an opportunity and boom, now you're making $57,000 a month, managing
SEO for small businesses and you have a team of 20 plus people and you're
making, you know, a lot of money, you live in the life you want to live.
And it's just, it's exciting.
So, um, guys, people like,
one last thought that I'll share is, um, it's actually crazy how many clients
we have that don't really care that much about SEO.
They like went with us because they just wanted a better looking website.
And those clients, I saw someone in the chat asked like about our retention.
Um, I've been doing this for like about two and a half years, like focusing on
this and we have clients that we've had for over a year, over two years because
they just like us, they like the look of their site.
They get most of their business from word of mouth anyway, but they
just want to be online.
And so like the SEO is like low priority for them.
So yeah, we're doing it and we're, we're doing the SEO, but they
don't actually care about it.
They are basically in their minds, they're just paying 500 bucks a month.
So they have a good looking website and someone that they can email to
make updates whenever they want.
Um, and yeah, like SEO is being done and they have like our expertise.
They can email and say, Hey, what should we do here?
We give them like their Google review links so they can text it out.
Like we do some things for them, but so many of these people are just like,
Oh, I'm just paying 500 bucks a month for my website, 300 bucks, bucks
a month for my website.
That's not something you cancel.
You want to have a website online.
And so it's, it's actually crazy.
Like I could tell, I could fire my whole SEO team.
We could stop making sales and there would still be probably about 10 to
20,000 monthly recurring revenue that would just sit there for years and years
and years because we have their website lives and that's all they care about.
It's pretty crazy.
So there's some people that really care and that, um, you know, we do
obviously do a great job for them, but we even do a great job for people
that don't care, but I just like talking with them.
I just know they're not going to turn cause they just like how their website
looks and they're going to pay us 500 bucks a month because like we're their
online guys and we're their only connection to like the online world.
And it's really weird, man.
Like you get those, you get those deals and you kind of know them.
And I'm like, this is the easiest craziest thing in the world, but they love
it because they feel confident in us taking care of it all really well.
So
these are like people that have just decided that they're just going to have
that monthly fee forever and they, they, maybe they haven't even consciously
decided, but yeah, to them, that's just how it is.
That's just the fee.
And that's one of the things Zach does really well is he's strategic about the
people that he targets and he's targeting people that are already comfortable with
this bill and, uh, that's what makes the retention.
So again, there's so many, there's so many commonalities with what I talk
about with what Zach's saying is when I always say, Hey, that, you know, the
money's made or lost in picking the right city in the right niche and picking
the business owner, you guys pick the right business owner in the right
city and niche, your retention is going to be so much lower.
You pick a high maintenance business owner.
I don't care how many leads you're piping them full of.
It's going to be difficult.
So it all comes down to how you do that.
And Zach has a really good system for how he selects those people and how
he goes after them, what he says.
And it's from the second you make that initial call until you close the deal.
But, um, anyway, Zach Powell, thanks for jumping on this call, dude.
Really appreciate it.
57 K per month from, uh, from what were you making before?
Around five to seven gross, um, 70,000 a year.
So like $4,500 a month.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Quite a bit different now.
It's crazy.
That's wild.
And, uh, here we are a couple of years later and I've, I've, I've seen
this firsthand in my life and I always say this is like, you're closer than
you think to getting to your, to the goals that you have in the life that
you, that you want.
And it's like, I think it's in this book at the beginning.
It talks about the three feet of being three feet from gold.
Um, I know for me, what eight months before I hit a hundred thousand dollars
a month, I was, I was $60,000 in debt.
I had no idea.
I was almost ready to give up on, on being a business owner.
And, uh, and I know for you, your, your growth was much more like stable and
consistent, but nonetheless, two and a half years ago, you were just paying the
bills and now you're building a new house, going to Nicaragua on a random
October week to, to go surfing, dude.
That's amazing.
I love that, bro.
The waves were good.
So how'd you go?
Well, guys check out that link.
Zach.
It's Zach.
Is it Zachary Powell or Zach Powell doc CEO?
You see what it is?
Yeah.
Zach Powell.
.co.
Powell with two L's.co go and check it out.
If you guys are interested, hit them up and, uh, go from there.
But Zach Powell, thanks bro.
Yeah.
Thanks Nick.
Appreciate it, man.
Okay.
We'll talk soon.
Thanks everyone.